y se diría que es rusia o canadá pero es
españa ante el temporal más intenso de
los últimos 50 años solo en 24 horas
madrid quedó sepultada por medio metro
de nieve el invierno sumado a la
borrasca filomena ha dejado estas
inusuales postales no exentas de un lado
menos amable más de 600 carreteras
quedaron cortadas en el país motivando
el despliegue de la unidad militar de
emergencias que ha socorrido a
centenares de pasajeros y transportistas
pero aún quedaría en el 30 por ciento de
personas afectadas sin recibir ayuda sin
contar con los viajeros de trenes y del
aeropuerto de barajas- que tuvo que
paralizar sus vuelos nos dijeron que
teníamos que evacuar recoger nuestra
maleta y esperar más noticias y esas
noticias fueron ninguna en toda la noche
y nos tuvimos que quedar a dormir aquí
nos dijeron que nos iban a llevar un
hotel ya y llevamos toda la santa noche
sin que nadie absolutamente nadie se
ocupe de nuevo si bien el bloqueo se
está viviendo sobre todo en madrid y en
comunidades cercanas el riesgo es
general 11.000 kilómetros de vías
requieren cadenas se teme por el
abastecimiento y por las personas que no
pueden pagar la electricidad mientras ya
se encuentran fallecidos incluyendo
personas sin hogar
había quedan por delante y hay que
decirlo muy claramente horas difíciles
por los que hay que pedir a la población
que extremen todas las medidas de
precaución en los próximos días
las nevadas van a pasar a ser heladas
vamos a tener un descenso importante de
las temperaturas con la incidencia y la
importancia centros educativos y
partidos de fútbol que han sido
suspendidos por unos días en esta españa
no preparada para los entre 20 50
centímetros de nieve que la han pintado
de blanco